I think this is a classic rock pose with
the eyebrows that signature eyebrows
look at that this is your this is the
kind of the pre-match is this the
pre-match yeah that's like the it's the
pre-match it's the preamble it's a
talking trash that is a I had a
catchphrase that that that went with is
that it doesn't matter
that's it doesn't matter how did it
doesn't matter what cuz it doesn't sound
like a catchphrase how did it work as a
catchphrase well whoever I was in the
ring with and stupids been there are
many occasions right so whoever I was in
the ring with so for example if it were
you and I had to be like Graham what do
you think you're gonna do tonight when
we get in the ring gunning to be in a
big action franchise yes fast and
furious I would love to be in fast and
furious to do those movies aren't they I
mean they're they're like just you don't
act it's amazing they set all these
things and things explode all around you
and oh it's unbelievable fun and that
would cause like that would be my dream
come true
we've heard your American accent few
times Chris what do you watch the wire
oh I love the wire did you know that a
dress was British not at all
he scared the [__] out of me scared of
him right now
but nobody knew you were pretty yeah no
I mean but the truth is a broad ition
for this for so long and they told me
you know don't come in with your English
accent it doesn't sound very some of the
great young New York actors it was a lot
of and I saw you in the lobby I would
just turn around your American accent
has not always been that good for you
right now I don't know what's go
you do the science of genetic space
precinct from 1904 oh yeah 1984 1990 94
that one did you have never seen well no
I've heard that there's a clip of it and
I had a quick look on YouTube they they
dubbed my voice all right it's not me
it's actually didn't even do a really
good American accent either they don't
sound like me
have you ever got you'd be doing oh so
so this this is Idris but very suckling
it's beautifully done the dubbing you
may not even notice that it's
non-interest speaking
cops are you involved with the police or
to me not to worry dog you just
concentrate on doing what you do best
being beautiful
sublight pizza
between the bay hot delivery anywhere on
out our guarantee you've got a force to
be reckoned with your father yes yeah so
he's a urologist he's your oldest yes so
there was like no topic off limits
basically and also like loves sort of
like loved embarrassing us because you
would bring well your sister would bring
friends out yeah I don't know what he
calls it like the third degree so you
like deliberately embarrasses him so at
my sister's first boyfriend the first
question he asks is are you circumcised
I don't know why there was like no
context Wow yeah
quite intense - yeah oh and I think it
was one
oh no yeah oh well I think release that
point was is like he was like a big
hypochondriac and I think he got worried
bit he had something like maybe flashed
on something like something mild and he
panicked and when I was like get him off
and so just just just examination yeah
because you know it's easier than
waiting for the GP I guess so much
waiting this is the NHS aren't that bad
I don't know are you already know I left
that I was just taking everything was
okay yeah I mean not even amazing either
me I would sooner go to a hospital in a
warzone he's very cool he's like he's
very cool he's just like I couldn't get
into clubs and stuff he'd take me in got
a picture of you here you are
yeah in the white house I met the man oh
look I was great sharing laughs you know
remember what you were laughing about
yeah know exactly wasn't about President
Obama at the time was telling me that I
was his second favorite character in The
Wire Oh
number one yeah Omar was his favorite
laughed out loud as you can see like
what happened here this can this picture
went all over the world what people said
you fell no no I didn't fall I didn't
and it wasn't a can it wasn't finished I
was at Venice Venice into the culture
now
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it was a staircase you can have to say
kissing there's the president everything
and you're supposed to say hello and as
I came up I noticed his shoelaces I'm
done you know your shoelace is undone
I'm going to do it up for you you won't
no no no no it's alright I'll do it up
for you so I sank very gracefully with
my movies you know very elegant I don't
know how this is quite the story
look at the guy on the right he's
laughing he's cuz you fell I know
Dwayne because you had a really long
connection with Muhammad Ali yes so my
dad used to box too as well and sparred
with Ali and Foreman then he got into
pro wrestling and when I was a kid I had
the opportunity to hang out with ollie
when I was six I think you posted a
picture so special isn't it that's a it
was it was very cool and and then when I
became a rookie in the WWE I saw him
again
and I went just to go say hello and pay
the respects and he kind of pulled me
back and got in my ear and he whispered
to me he's like can you rumble I think I
can I yeah and then and then a really
cool thing so you know as you know and
many of you may know he became the
people's champion like that was a
moniker right that he had so wrestling I
just started calling myself the people's
champion when I was a bad guy in honor
of him but I didn't let the crowd know
that so finally his family came to
Louisville Kentucky where we wrestling
one night the big family came and I saw
his wife and and I said hey I just I
meant no disrespect it's all out of
respect that I was calling myself that
do you don't know no Muhammad told me to
tell you he loves it and he wants you to
have the name I was like wow yeah it was
really really cool is really cool so
when he passed away obviously you know
like a lot of us it was very devastated
but really I just got to say it's such a
cool thing what you're doing and I love
boxing and especially women's boxing and
the ground you're breaking is so cool so
congrats
it's cubes Q's are dangerous for you
Q's for the toilet when you get
recognized in a queue for the toilet and
women's you know women's bathrooms you
know in theaters 'm and places like that
there's always a huge crate on queue and
that is not an easy place to be
recognized because you can't you're
stuck and then other people in the queue
and then word goes out and now you're
having a conversation with this whole
queue of people all the time slowly
moving towards the you know the cabinet
this empty and then knowing that
everybody's going to be listening it's
incredible it really is and so in all
those action sequences are you one of
those guys do you do all your own stunts
or I'd like to yeah I'd like to do a
good amount of sense because stunts are
fun and you know they're cool but more
so it's not really a ego thing it's more
so the audience knows I would rather tie
myself into all the action so they're
able to see yes but no I'm just thinking
in a stunt scene yes up man is having a
fight with you if you hit him you could
kill him
this isn't fair miss then the wind
behind the punch will give an ammonia
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there was one when I first started for
example I did the Scorpion King and it
was my very first movie and I had this
big action sequence and I wound up
hitting a stuntman
and kind of clocking him super hard he
was a little older he went down and I
felt so bad would you catch somebody you
know like with a point it just it
doesn't feel good so I bought him a
Rolex watch and he was bad I felt I felt
super bad because they're mean these
guys are the backbone of our business so
I did buy him a Rolex watch
but once that story gets out did then
some people just aren't throwing himself
what happened so this story starts
getting out and there's a couple you
know you're getting these action
sequences and maybe guys will lean I
mean if we got to fight what would would
that be worth it to know no one punch no
I can tell the time right now
[Music]
you